nazma Khan is commanding the bat
increase she's been playing Cricket for
a decade it's by far the most popular
sport in India Khan says it's the best
time for women to be playing the
gentleman's game there are more
platforms more opportunities for girls
now earlier we only got a job in the
Indian railways if we did well in
domestic Cricket men have many options
the new Women's Premier League will give
us more money and a chance to make a
name for ourselves
women's Cricket is getting a new
tournament the Women's Premier League or
wpl has five teams games will be played
in the T20 format and players will
include Indian and international Stars
the biggest names tend to earn up to
around four hundred thousand dollars for
three weeks work that's 10 times as much
as the women's 100 competition in
England and Wales the Women's Premier
League is already one of the world's
most valuable women's sporting
franchisee leagues the teams were
auctioned for more than half a billion
dollars that's more than what the men's
Indian Premier League raised when it
began 15 years ago and broadcast rights
sold for more than 100 million dollars
three team owners also have franchises
in the IPL Delhi Capital says it's
tapping into the growing demand for
women's sports if you look at the iPad
viewership right now close to 45 percent
of 45 percent of the viewership comes
from women So currently the IPL is
watched by close to 240 million women so
we are all very very bullish that the
commercial growth of this league is
going to be phenomenal
India's team has had a strong season the
under-19 squad recently won the T20
World Cup and the senior players reached
the semi-finals India's Cricket
Federation the BCCI recently announced
equal match fees for international male
and female players the whole idea is to
push the women Cricket because now
Australia New Zealand England the other
countries they are really pushing women
Cricket so
BCCI didn't want to lag bad because
unless you push them unless you bring
them at the Forefront how will you
realize the potential
the Federation says wpl success hinges
on how many people come to the stadiums
players hope the league will grow and
Inspire more girls to pick up a bat
New Delhi